hey y'all I'm Jerry hey I'm Darius I'm
Gabby I'm Monica and we're from cheer on
Netflix and we're here to take the
BuzzFeed quiz which to remember are you
how would your friends describe you
sweet snarky cool type a motivating or
famous motivating because pics anarchie
because they know that I'm very quick to
get picked tapi I picked sweet just cuz
I try to upload people cast someone to
play Monica in a movie about Navarro
cheerleading Reese Witherspoon Sandra
Bullock Kristen Wiig Nicole Kidman
Jennifer Aniston Cameron Diaz I'll go
with Sandra Bullock has that personality
that could fit me really well enrolling
your dream college course mastering Matt
talk tumbling for dummies do's and
don'ts in Daytona how to be more like
Monica pyramids 101 history of true
liberties I think I'm picking do's and
don'ts of Daytona because I think that's
super important I'm picking do's and
don'ts as they talk about choose the mat
talk you need to hear right now you're a
star you're beautiful you're doing
amazing how a pig you're doing amazing
bears on Netflix show you stranger
things spinning out sex education The
Witcher showing Adventures of Sabrina
I'm gonna go with you you're going with
stranger things because that's one of my
favorites it's change she's a snack to
indulge in on a day off potato chips
chocolate chip cookies
nachos ice cream pizza or pretzels
[Laughter]
[Music]
finally choose a fictional cheerleading
squad the Panthers from Friday Night
Lights
the Cheerios from Glee the Toros from
bring it on the clovers from bringing on
the river vixens from Riverdale and the
Ravens from like she told me how I used
to be like her when I was younger so
like the fact that I'm like get in there
and I'm like trying to be like I want to
be more like her
when I get older it just made me feel a
bit better I mean I love my answer
because I absolutely love Morgan and I
think she's a sweetheart and I mean
that's my girl so be sure to stream
cheer streaming on Netflix and make sure
to go to buzzfeed.com to take the quiz
to see which to remember you are
[Music]